مضيق باب المندب هو واحد من اهم خطوط
النقل بين مختلف القارات ممرنا اي يصل
البحر الاحمر بخليج عدن وبحر العرب مؤخرا
ابدت الكثير من الاوساط الدوليه قلقها من
امتلاك الميليشيات الحوثيه لقدرات تهدد
الملاحه البحريه في المضيق وكذلك في البحر
الاحمر خاصه بعد استخدام الميليشيات زوارق
مسيره مفخخه وايضا صواريخ مضاده للسفن
لمهاجمه السفن في السابقه المحلل السابق
في الاستخبارات العسكريه البريطانيه مارتن
كيلي هو احد المراقبين الذين يتوقعون
تصاعد التهديد للملاحه في باب المندب كيلي
يعمل حاليا كمحلل الاستخبارات في مركز
الاستشارات الامنيه في لندن وينضم الينا
الان لمناقشه هذه التوقعات اولا ان مصر
مارتن اهلا بك معنا في عسكريتاريا على اي
شيء تبني هذه التوقعات المتعلقه بتصعد
التهديدات الملاحه في مضيق باب المندب
خلال المرحله القادمه
زاد الحوثيون من خطابهم التهديدي
والرغبه في شم الهجمه في المجال البحريه
اليمني من ضمنها هجمه ضد خفر السواحل
اليمني وضد السفن التي يتهممها الحوثيون
بسبب النفط اليمني الى جانبه هجمات على
البناء التحتيه لمرافق الجنوب لقد حذر
الحوثيون مؤخرا من اندلاع مواجهه مع
التحالف على الجبهه البحريه واعلن ان امن
المناطق البحريه اليمنيه سيكون اولويتهم
في المرحله المقبله موشرين بذلك الى مضيق
باب المندب وخليج عدن ومياه سقطر
الاقليميه ومن الجدير بالذكر هنا انه من
غير المرشح ان يقوم الحوثيون بمهاجمه
السفن غير المنخرطه في النزاع او تلك التي
تحاول تصدير النفق من الموانئ التي لا
يسيرون عليها ومع ذلك يبقى احتمال ارتكاب
خطا في تحديد هويه السفن والاخطاء
الحسابيه قائما امم مستر مارتن فيما يتعلق
بالتهديد الاكبر هل تعتقد بانه سيكون
التهديد الاكبر هي الصواريخ المضاده للسفن
ام من قبل المسيررات
اطلاق الصواريخ من صنعاء هبطت في المياه
الدوليه
والحوثيون معروفون باستخدامهم تشكيله
واسعه من المسيرات الجويه والبحريه
فالتهديد قد يكون مصدره اي من المصادر
اعلاه
مستر مارتن هناك الكثير من الوحدات الان
تحاول الحفاظ على امن الملاحه سواء في
البحر الاحمر او حتى في مضيق باب المندب
ومنها وحدات تابعه للقياده المركزيه
الامريكيه برايك هل هذه الوحدات كافيه
للحفاظ على الامن في هذه المنطقه وان لم
تكن كافيه ما الذي تحتاجه هذه الوحدات لكي
تستطيع الحفاظ على الامن في هذه المنطقه
مضيق باب المندب
اعتقد ان القياده المركزيه سبق ان اتخذت
الخطوات اتجاه تامين البحر الاحمر من خلال
تاسيس قوه مهام البحر الاحمر في ابريل
العام الماضي وتركز هذه القوه على الامن
البحري الاقليمي وبناء القدره من خلال
بناء الشركه مع القوه البحريه وخفر
السواحل التابعه لدول المنطقه لتحسين
مشاركه المعلومات والتنسيق فهذه القوه
جلبت معها من سفينتين الى ثمان سفن
ومسيرات بحريه جويه مما يزيد من الوجود
العسكري في المنطقه ويحسن الدرايه
بالاوضاع وقدره الاستجابه في حال وقوع
حادث
لكننا يعني مستر مارتن يعني مؤخرا دائما
ما كانت هناك قوات امريكيه في هذه المنطقه
لحمايه الممرات المائيه المتعلقه بالملاحه
البحريه بشكل اخر لكن هناك بعض يعتقدون
بان الاهتمام الامريكي بهذه المنطقه قد
تراجع هل تعتقد بانه برغم كل هذه القوات
الولايات المتحده ليست لديها الرغبه
الكافيه للالتزام والحفاظ على الالتزامها
بالحفاظ على ان هذه المنطقه
كلها اعتقد ان امريكا لا تزال لديها رغبه
في تامين المنطقه يجب ان ننظر الى الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه لمضيق باب المندب فاي فاي
حديث في هذه المنطقه ستكون له عواقب وقيمه
على الاقتصاد العالمي فمن مصلحه القوه
العالميه كافه تامين امن هذه المنطقه خاصه
مع الولايات المتحده عبر القياده المركزيه
والقوات البحريه المشتركه مصر مارتن ذكرت
القوه العالميه والصين الان يعني يبدو
بانه دورها في منطقه الشرق الاوسط يتصاعد
بشكل كبير سواء على المستوى السياسي او
حتى المستوى الاقتصادي لكن برايك هل الصين
مؤهله للاعب اي دوري عسكري لحمايه او
للمشاركه في حما الممرات المائيه في هذه
المنطقه خاصه بانها مستفيد اقتصادي بشكل
كبير
هذه
البحريه الصينيه نشرت قوه خارجه جيبوتي
وقد سممت بالاصل لمكافحه القرصنه ولكن بما
ان هذا الخطر قد زال فهذه القوه هناك الان
لدعم جهود الامن البحري وفيما يخص تنفس
القوه بين امريكا والصين فهذه منطقه تنفس
في سياق اهدافها الاستراتيجيه الاوسع
فكلهما لديهم مصالح عسكريه واقتصاديه في
المنطقه ولكن التنفس الان ينصبوا على
الصعيد الاقتصادي والنفوذ وليس على القوه
العسكريه مستر مارتن بعيدا عن الصين
وبعيدا عن الولايات المتحده ما هو المطلوب
من دول المنطقه لتنميه قدراتها البحريه
للحفاظ على الملاحه البحريه في هذه
المنطقه خاصه بانها المسؤول المباشر عن
امن هذه المنطقه
يجب ان تركز على تحسين قدرتها الدفاعيه
البحريه والوعي البحري ويمكن ان يتحقق ذلك
بشكلين اولا من خلال تطوير والمحافظه على
قدره مراقبه واستطلاع بحريه قويه وثانيا
عبر تطوير امكانيه العمل المشترك مع
الشركاء الاقليميين والدوليين ولهذا وضعت
قوه مكافحه الارهاب 53 في المنطقه امام
حليا فعلى دول المنطقه التركيز على تعزيز
قدرات حفر السواحل لضمان امني وسلامه
السفن التي تعبر مياههم او تستخدم مرافقهم
مصر مارتن كيلي المحلل الاستخبارات في
مركز الاستشارات الامنيه اي او اس رزق كنت
معنا من لندن شكرا جزيلا على هذه التوضيحه